so heads are starting to roll after The
Escape of that convicted murderer the
man in charge of the state prison system
is now stepping down at the governor's
request this after a series of failures
inside the department 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been
exposing trouble inside the prison
system for nearly a year she's in our
Newsroom with more of the very latest
development Vanessa
Nevada's prison system is in shambles as
we've been reporting it has been for
months but the escaped prisoner is just
what seems to have gotten everyone's
attention
situation with the escaped inmate is a
serious and unacceptable breach of
protocol Governor Steve ciselak
announcing on Twitter Friday Nevada
prison's director Charles Daniels is
resigning at his request and six
correctional officers at Southern desert
Correctional Center are on
administrative leave for breaching
security protocols after The Escape of a
convicted murderer only made public
after the eight news now investigators
reported on it
for his capture Wednesday evening put
video Duarte Herrera was last accounted
for inside the prison Friday evening
discovered missing Tuesday Morning
agencies like the lvmbd and the U.S
Marshal Service say they weren't
notified until hours later that
afternoon it was when the first time
that any authorities within Nevada
uh we're aware of what was occurring out
at the the prison this is the same
prison where there was a riot in
December which the department tried
covering up after months of research we
exposed how bad it was prison insiders
have expressed concerns about Staffing
inmates say they're not receiving proper
Medical Care their loved ones trying to
sound the alarm about their safety at
High Desert State Prison earlier this
week a 69-year-old inmate beaten to
death earlier this month two suicides
within hours and last year an inmate who
was just about to be released stabbed to
death by his cellmate after numerous
warning signs we asked Governor sisalak
about the prison system in December and
do you think the doc needs to be more
transparent and are you doing anything
about it well we try to be as
transparent as we possibly can I'm
telling you from my research it seems
that High Desert State Prison is a mess
in there and not safe for the inmates
and the employees what would you do
moving forward to maybe look into it
well if you tell me that it's a mess in
there I can call it Direct when we
finish this interview and find out from
his side what's going on and encourage
him to be transparent then eight news
now investigator David Charles talked
with the governor Thursday the day
before he'd announced the director would
be stepping down my colleague Vanessa
Murphy has reported many times about
this interviewed you about it have there
been any consequences for this
department has there been any
consequences for the director it's been
a difficult uh situation to get under
control I had been requesting an
interview with the director for months
coming up I'll tell you about another
mistake made by the department which has
been kept Under Wraps